[Music]
in instafamous news oh let me do this
instafamous mean you're instantly famous
overnight on Instagram or just honest
room you became famos or just instantly
famous I thought it was famous on
Instagram yep oh you're correct like
your insta ho doesn't mean you're an
instant home your Instagram ho got it
but what about instant noodles
use now it's noodles on Instagram
instant compañeros if they've been told
about grandiose oh yeah they have yeah
they have um submitted by go tiger go
don't go didn't give a [ __ ] about these
burning oh [ __ ] my bowtie go go that and
he's just like he's just like this
you're saying go Tigers over it I
started noticing he stopped caring about
go Tyco ago when he stared at me and
this is his legs like dangling just go
tiger he goes he's giving you one little
kick he went
now I know how parents feel you're not
like we know when you're a kid and then
your parents like oh sure sure auntie
uncle got one thing [ __ ] [ __ ] again I
was [ __ ] four years ago but I'd be in
the parents minor fine caught a pop lock
for them
that was two months ago mom um a new
mural in LA is guarded with security and
only allows social media stars to pose
in front of it but now I think that's
just like a social statement I think is
pretty genius oh really what is there
yeah where these are Nelly right
downtown yes what street because we do
have certain murals that are
specifically for Instagram and stuff
like that too like those angel wings
yeah and if you have 20k followers and
above then you're allowed to take a
picture with it and they have a security
guard there I think it's a I think it's
a statement I snorted where is it cuz
there's this new article about it um
Melrose Avenue in West Hollywood Oh
guarding this 24-hour angel wings one
private mural for verified influencers
and people with over we apologize for
the inconvenience see security staff or
proof and access influencers please tag
us on social media it's like a thing
called like and subscribe I gotta be
real it's not even that cute
the other does the other angel wings
that are all over LA is better you know
what you want talking about pretty good
I know oh really
I'm not verified how do I get verified
I'm not verified either well no I
you have to like on everything else yeah
you aren't verified on Instagram you
know not really on Twitter oh wow how
should get verified on Twitter
okay so there's like the submission
thing on Instagram and they have to ask
you to like list your accomplishments
and I was like great
I'll go listen right now and I'll say
alright I have a lot of accomplishments
what the [ __ ] what are they I'm verified
on Instagram I think you're the only one
yeah Nikki - Nikki's verified after I
did the film I got verified oh so we got
to do our film and we get verified or
you just need a publicist
okay yeah anybody that's a good
publisher you guys need a publicist yes
we do publicist hey Dave it's like I
don't know you black dude I want to skip
that step I want money
alright you guys no money genie anywhere
anybody no money out there or a
leprechaun I'll take a leprechaun
there's a gamble with a leprechaun can I
kill you if you think it's gold its
co-op [ __ ] his ass up he's gonna steal
my cereal I'll give him marshmallows are
used to be scared of that leprechaun
movie you're the horror movie because
it's scary yeah if you watch it again
it's hilarious and as an adult it's like
wait why is he scary it's for kids right
yeah what does it call leprechaun I want
to watch it she's scared of it still
that I'm scared of others also
leprechaun leprechaun - leprechaun in
the hood try to relate to like a wider
audience
and like I was scared so he came out he
came out the pot of gold with gold
chains instead
what's that beachy activity where cholo
yeah the trailer baby I could die from
laughter no I mean it was it was funny
it wasn't happening over the top yeah it
was really stupid what the bug is yeah
so like and subscribers who put this
together right but if you go to it's
like your subscribe I don't know this
thing like I don't know what it is the
random pages 21 followers yeah so they
couldn't even take a photo wait they're
the ones that set it up this is well
that's what it says here it says please
tag like and subscribe oh I feel like
it's best so no one's tagging them cuz
they only got 21 followers
well the tag doesn't give you a follow
but that's the goal you get people to
tag each other yeah that it would blow
up their Instagram or something by
having alright so what do you think this
statement is saying like you only bug
get things now because you're famous you
got followers so so what some people are
saying is that this is a troll thing so
it's like a it could be like a bigger
for you to look at how now there's like
this hierarchy of like how many
followers you have a famous you are like
we can only do certain things a lot of
people are saying that this reminds them
of that one black mayor episode we're
like you have to constantly Google from
everyone and so what do you mean like
now like that it's always been like that
like if you're famous you get special
treatment like it's always been that way
like the 15 or 20 years ya been in a
society yeah but I get nothing's it's so
readily available to the masses now it's
like more people like anybody to be
common people yeah that's true it's not
just for people who want to be too
famous it's people who want to be famous
but I guess like more people can be
famous now it's more accessible to the
common person now now we live in the era
of the wedding singers are also real
singers oh yeah that's right or some
[ __ ] animals or celebrities and [ __ ]
oh that's what the dog can party the
other day and this guy walked in with
this dog and he was like 'hey i can't
run what it was he was like yeah this is
like swaggy dog yes wagging dog the pink
with my thing so yeah he had like dive
tub but like this guy walked in when
this dog is like this is swaggy dog like
everybody was like a man or something
like that they were all taking pictures
of this dog and i was like dog up my
followers me don't even sure they're all
famous world is about social currency
now man like it's super important like
you could try to fight as much as you
want but that's just how its evolving
like I just does that man I'm richer
than you
haha yes it does okay but he's verified
damage in Harlem see when it don't get
hurt David it doesn't feel good
that's literally his life model David
roasts only worked when it hurts them
but didn't hurt him so now I'm sad I got
counter roasted like your roast is
ineffective and hurts you like I guess
it means you're a loser ha fat boys
[Laughter]
respond to trolls boy just like no I
just [ __ ] with them even more don't like
oh it's because uh you like kids um yeah
because I rape them so interesting my
thing is how I see it is like if it's a
young kid that likes to write things or
even an adult and likes to write things
to get attention and that makes them
happy just give it to them
like that's all they got they respond to
those yeah but I respond to them because
I'm trying to think of a funny roast
yeah I mean like it's it's fun game for
you it's fun so it's like okay cool it's
not like I'm sitting there dwelling on
it but like you might like I've kind of
when we first started doing you to be
used to bother me but then I think about
it like if they if that's the one thing
that makes them happy and that's how
they interact then whatever just give it
to them it's another way to win your
followers over to I mean like it's
another way to show comedy and yeah when
some people write stupid [ __ ] like I
think I just had a recent post about her
new car and one of the comments are oh
how are you supposed to afford that this
JK make that much and I was like oh it's
because you also sell drugs on the side
don't you forget yeah you're gonna be
doubles be extra don't you I think my
response just depends on my mood that
day but like my general response is like
like are you like so much hate on Smosh
but like whenever somebody says
something read they'll talk about like
paragraphs impaired
yeah I'm Mikey I'm like okay you know
what this kids having a bad day and I'm
gonna let him have a bad day because I
actually didn't do anything wrong or
I'll respond I'll be like shut up
William and they're like what yeah I
mean it was like his name will be like
William and their thing and I'll
literally just be like shut up William
and then they just they don't really
know what to do there I'm sorry I
respond like oh my god I just wanted
attention from you you just wanna thank
you so much Patti or even if I did
something wrong I don't care that is
what it is they're like you're wrong
yes I was no - doubt some that the world
is a really soft place now some guy
wrote something on one of my comments
and I wrote look here [ __ ] and then I
had an explanation right and then a
bunch of comments Oh Bart when he called
them [ __ ] I don't like what [ __ ] is
such a soft word no yeah that's why I
like what people say like you'll see
this guy roast somebody and I listen to
it I'm like where's the roast yeah yeah
Bart waited he killed him he roasted I'm
like I did say so when I when I started
writing back things they're like yo
that's too far I was like but that's a
roast you're supposed to go people are
really soft nowadays there's so much not
only means you burn the [ __ ] out of them
dude okay yeah so when I yeah what
that's too far me yes I watch videos and
this guy's like talking about a kid is
like that kids so stupid they're so dumb
and that heroes begin but then I'll
write some stuff like that kids [ __ ]
dumb as [ __ ] he's so [ __ ] ugly he's
the algol mastery right yeah and they'll
be like that's too far bro I'm like but
that's what roasting all of you guys
need to follow or not yourself not you
guys are hard but some of your soft
friends put them on Jeffrey Ross he is a
man is the roast King that's a rose what
are you talk [ __ ] about other people I
get hurt
like you got to get those people that
like roast and they like find out what
you hate about yourself and they like
pull it out now like oh this how about
favorite roast of all time was was it
flava flav and then came there right
before like carrot tops roast yeah dude
I could not stop laughing those is one
joke that they said about flavor I
forgot who said this but he said that
flava flav looked like a skeleton
wrapped with electrical tape that's just
funny that's gross
yeah and sometimes to like what people
like make fun of me if it's funny like
I'll crack the [ __ ] up
but if you make a joke and is bad I'll
block you not be insulting it's just
really hard to read yeah it's cringy
it's very why are you trying so I like
to get it oh you look like Kim Jong
bleep what if they're practice roasting
oh it's not good though
you got to practice with your friends
for it before you put into public about
the practice on the white belt I'm
trying really hard to get my attention I
purposely don't respond at all and I
respond to everyone else that's positive
yeah
[Music]